[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler anthony
gratacos secrétaire général de la gauche
républicaine et socialistes bonsoir
anthony gratacos merci de sont avec nous
avec nous également en direct alexandre
tous ses vices présidents à l'ère du
département d'essonne merci d'être avec
nous même un petit peu plus loin mais en
tout cas sur ce plateau par le débat
pour commencer automne ibra tacos une
gratacos pardon une réaction commentaire
de cet homme évidemment meurtri ce papa
qu'on vient de voir les pouvoirs publics
de l'époque se sont comportés comme des
lopettes c'est dur mais est ce qu'il y
avait du vrai dans cette critique selon
vous alors tout d'abord je voudrais
commencer par saluer et rendre hommage
aux services de l'état aux enquêteurs
qui ont permis la tenue digne de ce
procès qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
ce procès c'est d'abord un procès pour
les victimes
mais c'est aussi un procès pour la
nation toute entière et pour l'histoire
alors évidemment je comprends l'émotion
de ce père que je viens d'entendre mais
je crois que l'état
à a joué son rôle dans la prise en
charge des victimes dans
l'accompagnement des victimes et des
familles parce que ce n'était pas leur
enfant qui était visé en particulier
c'était la société toute entière qui
était visé à travers ces attentats
c'était notre mode de vie nos façons de
penser et est donc c'est le rôle de
l'état de répondre à ses besoins à cet
accompagnement qui est nécessaire qui va
durer longtemps pour les victimes et
leurs familles là vous êtes dans
l'accompagnement des victimes et
effectivement c'est un point important
également reviendra après justement sur
comment l'état à gérer les failles
éventuellement par ce qui va en est
évidemment question tout au long de ce
procès mais restons effectivement dans
cet accompagnement des victimes
françois hollande je te l'avais
sacralisé cet accompagnement sous la
forme d'un secrétariat d'état qui était
rattaché aux services du premier
ministre
rattaché donc
au premier ministre de l'époque
portefeuille détenue par juliette mais
adel on regrette alexandre 11 et la
disparition de ce secrétariat d'état
j'écoutais effectivement c'était c'était
une novation il a été poursuivi soit une
forme interministériel je pense qu'il
faut dépasser la forme pourrait que
l'état fait un effort substantiel pour
accompagner les victimes
individuellement et aussi peut-être
collectivement parce qu'il ya tout un
effort qui est fait un lieu de mémoire
étant en prévision justement pour aussi
que la nation puisse
passer
ce moment important ce souvenir essayer
de davantage le comprendre alors bien
sûr et je m'associe à l'hommage qui
était probablement rendu par mon
collègue je pense qu'il faut avoir une
pensée à ce moment à la fois pour toute
et victimes leurs familles et toutes
celles et ceux qui sont intervenus ce
soir là les forces de secours et forces
de sécurité à l'intérieur on avait
célébré il ya quelques années et qu'on
dénigre trop facilement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
vous comprenez anthony gratacos aussi la
colère de certaines victimes on a vu ce
papa évidemment qu'il ne souhaite même
pas participer au procès une autre
colère celle des victimes qui ont
entendu aujourd'hui un accusé salade et
cela nous dire voilà je suis dans le
combat tout simplement est resté mutique
en revanche sur le reste cette colère
elle est compréhensive aujourd'hui
clairement bien sûr que je la comprends
la colère elle est humaine mais la
réponse à la barbarie à laquelle on a
été confrontée elle ne peut pas être la
colère elle ne peut être que la dignité
et ce procès c'est la réponse
républicaine à la barbarie à laquelle on
a été confronté lors certaines victimes
certaines familles des victimes ils
trouveront du réconfort et d'autres non
je crois que c'est le cas de cette
famille ils le trouveront dans autre
chose mais on est en france dans un état
de droit où c'est la justice qui doit
permettre que les victimes trouvent une
réponse dans ce qui est dans ce qui
s'est passé on risque d'avoir du mal à
obtenir des réponses des accusés mais au
moins l'histoire sera dit alors
aujourd'hui évidemment on va pas faire
le procès on serait bien en peine de le
faire et on ne se le permettrait pas
bien évidemment mais il est question des
files tous les deux des responsables
politiques qui représentez votre parti
il ya bientôt des élections
présidentielles on ne va pas se voiler
la face clairement ces failles
pour vous elles ont été clairement
présente on aurait pu peut-être éviter
certaines choses on rappelle que la
plupart des accusés était connu par les
services de renseignement il y a des
progrès à faire évidemment sans faire le
procès aujourd'hui ce soir de ces
attentats elle explosé
alors écoutez je répète mes propos
soient mal utilisées la hausse et le
procès de terroristes c'est le procès de
l'islam politique c'est pas le procès de
la france en les principaux responsables
de ces actes terroristes
ils sont sur le banc des accusés c'est
pas pays c'est pas le gouvernement voilà
ceux ci
ceci étant dit c'est vrai que notre pays
à mon avis n'a pas bien appréhendé à
l'époque s'effeuille nouveau autour de
tueries de masse et à peut-être
sous-évalué de risques de départs
de jeunes français sur zone à peut-être
sous-évalué ses poteaux et acquis qui
secret a peut-être pas à créer les
services de renseignements qu'on a pu
dont le développement a suivi puisqu'on
a comblé ses lacunes et il est vrai que
la commission d' enquête
menée par le député fenech à l'époque à
relever aussi un son de problème sur
le renseignement sur la coopération
entre les pays notamment
entre la belgique et la grèce a relevé
aussi des sujets d'intervention des
forces de sécurité ces différents
problèmes je pense
aux était plutôt réglé
pour autant on a d'autres problèmes qui
arrivent aujourd'hui face à une mutation
de ce terrorisme avec stéphane appelle
le terrorisme d'atmosphère sert des
situations beaucoup plus individuelle
des petits groupes beaucoup plus
difficile à détecter et là je pense
qu'on n'est pas à nouveau aujourd'hui
pour lutter efficacement contre ces
nouveaux phénomènes on va en reparler en
tout cas on parler de cet enjeu
politique puisque encore une fois il est
bien réel ancien président de la
république à l'époque françois hollande
a accepté de témoigner il sera
auditionné le 10 novembre prochain je
vous propose de l'écouter
pour répondre à toutes les questions qui
me seront posées à la fois sur ce
qu'était la situation internationale et
notamment ceux qui se produisait en
syrie et en irak quelle est l action de
la france et pourquoi avait-elle lancé
des opérations contre les terroristes
islamistes dans cette région je
répondrai à toutes les questions sur ce
qu'on est et mes décisions
anthony gratacos il a sa place
clairement le l'ancien président de la
république à cette audience est
important qu'ils s'expriment et qu'ils
l'expriment sa version également oui je
crois qu'il est tout à fait légitime il
était en responsabilité dont il a été un
acteur important de
2,2 ce moment et des attentats ce n'est
pas que qu'un moment c'est aussi un
contexte et donc je pense que françois
hollande va aussi expliquer le contexte
dans lequel ça s'est déroulé
clairement françois hollande a on l'a
entendu chez nos confrères de france
info aujourd'hui
exclu toute erreur de la part du du
gouvernement ça vous semble être la
réponse appropriée clairement alexandre
12 est aujourd'hui de la part du
président de la république
ancien
encore une fois la responsabilité elles
émanent elle appartient aux terroristes
c'est pas le gouvernement français qui a
fait ces tueries de masse et parce que
je crois que la défense des
terroristes n'hésitera pas j'allais dire
à relever nos querelles internes pour
essayer de justifier ou d'excusé plus
une plus ou moins les actes ignobles
conflit accompli par ceux celles et ceux
qui sont sur le banc des accusés donc je
pense qu'il faut très clairement dire
que la responsabilité sont des
terroristes et le projet de l'islam
politique et après est ce que le
gouvernement était assez efficace ça
c'est une question qu'on peut se poser à
une commission dans lequel qui a relevé
un ensemble de faits notamment sur
comment on organise des forces de
sécurité intérieure qui intervient en
premier
quel et les pouvoirs de la force
sentinelle est ce que la berri était
peut-être la plus capée printemps les
gains sont deux questions qui ont été
posées ces questions là je pense que
globalement
la france amélioré et renforcé son
enseignement elle a renforcé la
coopération avec les pays étrangers elle
a admis l'idée que globalement on l'a vu
à nice très récemment en présence de
l'attentât où c'est la police municipale
qui était la première sur place qui est
intervenu donc il ya toute une série de
réformes de la doctrine
de techniques d'intervention du
renseignement qui sont intervenus par
contre là où je m'inquiète c'est
effectivement comment on va s'adapter à
ce terrorisme entre guillemets un peu
plus là tu qu'on a pu voir la rue des
frères c'est du terrorisme de masse
comme on a eu en septembre qu'on a eue
là au bataclan
ce terrorisme de masse je peux me disent
les services de renseignement c'est qu'
il est plus difficile aujourd'hui à
mettre en oeuvre parce qu'il n'ya pas le
soutien des bases arrières qui
permettrait de à ce jour 1 je pense
qu'il fallait prudent de le rencontrer à
nouveau ce
système de tueries de masse mais il les
derniers faits dont les plus le
terrorisme plus individuel je dirais pas
le bout solitaire parce que pour moi
c'est une expression qui ne me convient
pas et là il faut vraiment très
clairement à adapter notre modèle qui a
toute la question de la bataille
culturelle et éducative
c'est à dire est ce que l'on considère
qu' on laisse franchement c'est une
auberge espagnole où on leers on laisse
toutes les expressions se développer ou
est ce qu'on affirme des valeurs
républicaines la laïcité l'éducation
la culture l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes au fond est-ce qu'on est une
société libérale anglo saxon où on fait
cohabiter des communautés et tout va
bien tant qu'à se tape pas dessus ou est
ce qu'on dit qu'on est une démocratie et
une république avec des valeurs a
affirmé donc il ya à la fois je pense
faire progresser le technique
d'intervention le renseignement
j'allais dire aux contenus que je pense
à la reconnaissance faciale par exemple
et puis aussi avoir un combat culturel
éducatif
républicain au sein de paix anthony
gratacos aujourd'hui clairement vous
vous sentez davantage en sécurité en
france
que au lendemain de ces attaques mais je
pense que comme l'a dit alexandre je
pense que monsieur touzet se trompent
d'abord il réfléchit pas à la bonne
échelle on est surtout dans le contexte
qu'on connaît depuis quelques semaines
on efface on était face à un terrorisme
international là où il y a eu une faille
bien sûr il y a eu des problèmes dans
les services français mais qui sont
minimes au regard des failles qu'il y a
eu dans les échanges entre les services
européens c'est l'accès les champs
belges et français belges et français
mais grecque ces terroristes et les
organisateurs de ces attentats ont
voyagé à travers l'europe ils étaient
fichés dans certains pays suivie dans
d'autres et ça n'a pas été communiqué
alors aujourd'hui l'europe a réagi
depuis 2015 et un centre européen du
renseignement qui a été créé aux pays
bas on est passé de l' échange bilatéral
entre services à un échange qu'on
appelle multi complet c'est à dire que
maintenant on échange tout avec tout le
monde sauf que ça représente une masse
de données et d'informations colossal à
traiter donc il faut y mettre les moyens
humains et là dans le contexte qu'on
connaît c'est à dire la prise de
l'afghanistan par les talibans qui peut
être une base arrière pour des
terroristes internationaux pour se
financer s'organiser et s'entraîner on a
plus que jamais besoin d'une coopération
et moyens internationaux pour lutter
contre après vous se trouvait à raison
sur un point c'est qu'on a un sujet
crucial moi j'appelle le terrorisme
discount c'est la personne qui en france
se radicalise via les réseaux sociaux
prend le premier couteau qui lui passe
sous la main et commet un attentat dans
la rue en bas de chez lui ça c'est du
service de renseignement fin et on n'a
pas vraiment vous parler d'efficacité
des services français le problème c'est
qu'on connaît les échecs des services
mais on n'en connaît pas par nature la
réussite puisque c'est frappé du secret
défense et c'est aussi bien d'ailleurs
que les terrorismes connaissent pas et
pour avoir des services secrets français
chacun sait que beaucoup de dates en
tapant là
ministre de l'intérieur jose attentats
ont été déjoués tu ne peux pas vraiment
en évaluer la réalité on peut estimer
effectivement que ça arrive assez
souvent pour rebondir saura vos propre
est vraiment j'insiste oui l'échelle
idoine aujourd'hui pour la lutte contre
ce terrorisme international c'est
l'europe justement je voudrais vous
faire avec côté l'analyse de tivo de
demandes rihanna le président du centre
de réflexion sur la sécurité intérieure
la menace terroriste est revenu au même
niveau de danger qu'en 2015 pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord on a sur notre
territoire beaucoup de gens qui sont
allés au jihad et qui sont revenus ces
gens là capacité de mener des actions
militaires coordonnées la deuxième
raison c'est qu'al-qaïda a cité la
france comme son ennemi principal dans
ces deux dernières vidéos
alexandre 11 est d'accord avec ce
diagnostic de de thibault de montbrial
tout à fait je crois qu'on est visée
parce que on exprime valeurs fortes de
la laïcité qui est assez propre à la
france on a la question bien sûr des
caricatures qui nous met aussi
en avant par rapport à d'autres pays et
puis je rajouterais toute la promenade
des sortants de prison
c'est à dire que nous avons tout un
sujet du risque endogène et je partage
n'y a pas de différence entre nous voilà
ce qui a été dit sur le risque
effectivement de nouvelles bases d'état
qui commencent à se consolider que ce
soit 2,2 de poche de proto est axée sur
scène
on avait une chance j'ai pas de sujets
là dessus mais on a un énorme risque en
interne avec des sortants de prison qui
ont été condamnés avant 2015 avant que
les peines soient fortes avec des
personnes extrêmement radicaliser avec
des personnes qui n'ont pas été
condamnés pour faits de terrorisme mais
qui se sont radicalisées maison
et puis on a une partie de la jeunesse
qui aussi berric vers une forme de
radicalité religieuse qui est pas
forcément aujourd'hui une radicalité
violente qui s'expriment souvent à
travers une expression
religieuse extrêmement forte
mais qui passent pas nécessairement à la
ddt on voit bien qu'on a tout un risque
endogène
aujourd'hui qu'on ne maîtrise pas
suffisamment
regard de son ampleur et malgré ça je
partage l'investissement des services
l'investissement des policiers sur le
terrain l'investissement des services
sociaux des collectivités sur le terrain
parce qu'il s'agit aussi de
d'accompagner socialement certaines
familles de surveiller certains
individus et on est là face à une masse
critique extrêmement
importante anthony gratacos le mot de la
fin pour pour vous clairement ce que
emmanuel macron tant que chef de l'état
a pris la mesure de ce que vous décrivez
comme menacés et problème pour le front
du terrorisme
concernant emmanuel macron
vous êtes socialiste il va défendre son
bien emmanuel macron à un moment donné
assez rapidement
les candidats de la présidentielle
puisque c'est l'inquiétude de nos
compatriotes c'est une question qui est
trans partisane où vous voyez bien que
avec monsieur touzet on est d'accord sur
la plupart des sujets il peut y avoir
des comment dire des nuances il peut y
avoir aussi un problème de cohérence par
rapport à ce qu'on défend et à ce qu'on
fait c'est à dire que des gouvernements
qui ont été au pouvoir on empanne eu les
moyens aussi dans ses services pour
pouvoir faire de la prévention contre le
terrorisme on a connu une politique
d'austérité très grande à partir de
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy à la tête
de l'état je suis pas sûr que ça n'ait
pas eu un rôle dans l'appauvrissement
des services les manques de moyens en
personnel et la diminution même de ses
personnels dans ses services il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
il faut admettre que emmanuel macron de
ce côté là pour ce qui concerne j'ai
plein de reproches à lui faire sur
beaucoup d'autres services de la
fonction publique mais en la matière
dans la foulée des politiques qui ont
été engagées après 1015 il les a pas
remis en cause il les a plutôt encouragé
merci à tous les deux ans tony attaques
de sources plateau alexandre vous et
merci à vous d'avoir accepté ce débat ce
soir etc